[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES BLAIR: So the goal
here is to just walk through
like a really simple use case
of plumbertableau to highlight
a couple of things-- one,
how it relates to Plumber
and how it extends what
Plumber can already do.
And then the other piece
here is to just showcase
what is plumbertableau trying
to solve from the developer
perspective.
So as an R user, what do
I get out of this tool?
And then the other side is as
a Tableau developer or Tableau
user, how do I leverage
something that's been developed
in plumbertableau?
What's the workflow, and what's
the pattern for using this
once it's been developed?
So that's the goal here.
I think there might be a
few assumptions about--
prerequisite Plumber
knowledge, but I'll
try to highlight some
of the main ideas
if there's some
unfamiliarity there.
But just like I said, the use
case here is really simple,
but I think it will
help us ignore--
or not necessarily
ignore, but it'll
give us something
concrete that we
can work with that's not overly
complex so that we can focus
instead on how the tool is
working rather than what we're
trying to accomplish with it.
So all that being
said, the idea is
I want to capitalize some text--
super easy.
But and in R, I could do
that with just the toupper
function that's already
there, but to make
this a little bit
easier to think about,
we're going to create our
own function called caps,
which takes some input text.
And then we're going
to use toupper in here
on our input text.
So again, nothing
crazy, but the idea
is we can give this
some sort of string,
"HELLO WORLD,"
and we'll get back
the capitalized form of that.
Now, let's say that
for some reason
this functionality is super
critical to some Tableau
document that I have.
I have a bunch of
text, and it has
to be capitalized
for my executives,
and this is the way
I'm going to do it.
Now, it's a stretch,
but that's the scenario
we're going to work with.
So the idea is this function
right now just lives in R,
and what I really
want is first, I
want to make this accessible
to other tools generically,
and then we'll
worry about Tableau.
So one of the ways to do that
is to use the Plumber package
and to turn this function that
we've defined into an API.
So I'm going to
bring in Plumber now.
And then Plummer works
by using special comments
to change existing R functions,
like what we have written here,
into API endpoints that
can respond to common HTTP
requests.
So it's nice in the sense
that I don't necessarily
have to write a bunch of new
code to turn this into an API.
I just have to add some
new comments to do that.
So we're going to come in.
And the special
signifier for Plumber
is the standard comment symbol
followed by an asterisk,
and then there are
these decorators
that begin with the
@ symbol that we
can use to define different
pieces and components of what
we want Plumber to do and
how we want it to handle
the functions we define.
So I'm going to create
an API title here.
We'll call this "Simple
capitalization example."
We'll give it a description--
"Capitalize some text."
So this is just a generic
title and description
for the API and collection
of different endpoints.
In our case, we're only
building this one function,
this caps function.
So I'm going to create a
little description for this.
This is "Capitalize input
text and return the result."
And then here's the
significant part.
Here's where I define--
OK, we're going to
listen for POST requests
at the "capitalize" path.
So here's the significant
part where I tell
Plumber, look, respond to
these types of requests
at this location.
And whenever a request comes
in that matches that criteria,
this function will be
executed with the contents
of that request on a
very simplified way.
So I'm going to just
go ahead and save this
here so that we can use some
of the RStudio niceties.
So now, once I've saved
this as a Plumber file,
you'll see that RStudio
gives me this Run API option.
And if I select this here, we
get this cool little interface
that pops up in our viewer pane.
And this is a UI,
user interface,
that's been
generated dynamically
by Plumber in combination with
Swagger, which is the rendering
tool that's been used here.
And this shows us, here's our
title, here's our description.
And if I change the
values where we see
"Capitalize some text"
is what we see over here.
And if I went back and
changed that and we ran this,
we'd see the change
updated here.
And if I come down
here to capitalize,
we can expand this out.
We see our input text here.
We see some information
about the different types
of responses we might get
back, and I can actually
go ahead and try this out,
and we can say "hello world,"
and we can hit Execute,
and there we go.
We have our response
back capitalized
form of what the input
that we provided, awesome.
Now, at this point,
we've done 95%
of the work necessary to get
this to work inside of Tableau.
And in fact, if we just take
a step back and ignore Tableau
for a second and think about
what we've done more broadly,
we've taken this
function that we wrote,
the "Capitalize this
text," and we've
turned it into this
service that can be used,
regardless of the
tool that's using it.
Like I could-- somebody writing
Python, or somebody writing Go,
or somebody writing
C++, or Java,
or whatever could call out
to this service and say, hey,
here's some text to capitalize,
and then R would execute what
it needs to do and return
back the capitalized text.
So it made this very generic
interface to function
but which can be
super, super useful.
Now, at this point, if I want
to get this to Tableau, I have--
into Tableau, there's a
couple of routes I could go.
One is I could
start figuring out
how exactly Tableau
wants to communicate
with external services.
Tableau has a very
specific way of sending
requests and a very specific way
in which it expects responses.
And I could go through,
and I could build out
an API that meets
that criteria or meets
the contract that Tableau
expects an API to be.
Or I could use the
plumbertableau package, which
does all of that work for me.
And so I'm going to go ahead
and bring in plumbertableau now,
which, as the name
suggests, is a package that
expands the
functionality of Plumber
to make it easy to
build APIs essentially
that operate as analytics
extensions inside of Tableau.
So once I bring the
plumbertableau package in,
there's two things
that I now need to do.
One is there's a couple
of new annotations
that I need to provide when
I describe my function.
One is @tableauArg, and
then one is @tableauReturn.
And as you can probably
guess from the naming,
@tableauReturn is where
we define the arguments
that we expect Tableau
to be providing--
in this case, that's
this input text argument.
And we might have
multiple arguments.
We could have input text
one and input text two,
or we can have different things.
Maybe there's
parameters-- again,
this is a very simple
use case, but perhaps I
have a previously trained
machine learning model,
and I'm expecting Tableau
to submit new data,
and then I'm going to run
that new data through my model
and generate
predictions and then
send the predicted
outcomes back to Tableau
for further analysis.
In which case, I might have a
dozen or more different inputs
that I expect to come from
Tableau, and each one of those
can be accompanied by this
@tableauReturn specification
here that allows me to
define some information
about that argument.
So here, I'm going
to say this is
input_text is the name of the
argument, and its type is--
if I could spell.
Its type is character.
And then here's a
brief description.
This is the text we
want to capitalized.
Easy enough?
@tableauReturn is what is
my extension sending back
to Tableau?
I first need to define what
data type I'm sending back.
So again, I'm going
to be sending back
a character, value, and this
is the capitalized input text.
So those two new things--
@tableauArg and @tableauReturn.
And the last piece here is I
need to add this modifier down
at the bottom, and
a modifier is simply
a function that makes changes
to an existing Plumber router.
So here, the way to do
that in this context
is to use this
Plumber decorator,
and then we're going to
say tableau_extension.
And this is a
function-- in fact,
if we can just look at
this really quickly.
This is a function that is
exported from plumbertableau.
It's one of the only functions
that the package actually
exports.
And this-- there's
an example here
of how you might use that in the
way that we're using it here.
But essentially,
this function does
all the necessary modification
to the underlying API
so that it matches
and behaves the way
that Tableau wants it to.
And the advantage here is this
means that as the R developer,
I don't need to necessarily
worry about how Tableau
is communicating with my API.
I can trust that the API will
communicate appropriately,
as long as I use this modifier
once I've defined everything
that I want to
define within my API.
OK, so I'm going
to save the file.
Again, just to
review-- we brought
in the plumbertableau package.
We added @tableauArg
and @tableauReturn,
and we modified the API
with this tableau_extension
function.
You might notice
that I'm not actually
executing the function,
and that's just
the semantic of Plumber itself.
So here is the function name
or the function reference.
I'm not executing
the function, but I'm
indicating call this
function on the API
that's previously defined and
allow that function to modify
the API as it needs to.
With these changes in place,
if I run the API again,
I see basically the
same page, but there's
a few subtle differences.
One is these new
links show up here.
These are
automatically generated
as part of this
plumbertableau package,
and we won't spend time
looking at them here,
but we will in a moment once
we transition to deployment.
But if I scroll down and open up
my capitalized endpoint again,
now, things look very different.
And the reason is because one of
the things that plumbertableau
does is it automatically
will create and generate
documentation about how
Tableau is going to interact
with this particular extension
as well as an example
request of what Tableau
is going to submit.
So here, this request that
we see here is in the format
that Tableau will be
submitting requests.
Tableau submits a JSON object
with two nested values, script,
and data, and so we see
those referenced here,
and then the data object
contains the actual data
values that are being
passed over from Tableau.
If we inspect this, we can see
that arg1 is the first value
here, and if we look
just above this,
this table here shows a mapping
between what my function in R
has defined and what
Tableau is going to submit.
So we can see that input text
in my R function corresponds
to arg1 in this
Tableau data object.
It's a character type
value, and here's
a description of what that
value is, and it's not optional.
It's a required field.
I can still try this out,
so I can click Try It Out.
I can come in here and
change the value of arg1
to "hello everyone."
Execute this, and
if we scroll down,
we see the capitalized
version of that text being
returned back.
Now, I'm going to pause
there and highlight
a couple of things.
One is as the R developer here,
I haven't touched Tableau.
I haven't opened Tableau.
I haven't needed
to look at Tableau.
I haven't needed to
visit Tableau's website.
But regardless of that, I've
been able to build an extension
and verified that it
will work with Tableau,
because I have an example of
what a Tableau request will
look like.
Let me just open this
up one more time.
When I click Try It Out in here
and run this request, and say,
"this is a test,"
this is me verifying,
yep, this extension seems to
be doing exactly what I expect
it to be doing, and
I have confidence
that it will behave that way
when it's connected to Tableau.
So the advantage is I can
do all of this within a tool
that I'm comfortable
and familiar with.
In this case, I'm using
RStudio Workbench.
I might be using
RStudio on my desktop.
I might not be using RStudio.
I might be developing
this in some other editor
or some other form.
But regardless, I have
access to this interface,
either directly in
RStudio or in a browser,
and I can test to verify
the behavior of my extension
without needing to either
open Tableau myself
or rely on somebody
that has Tableau access,
and that was one of our goals.
If I take a step
back and just look
at some of the philosophies
that went into designing
plumbertableau, part
of this was to say
we want to make things easy
for both populations here.
One is the developers.
How do we make
things easy for them?
We build and extend tools
that they're already
comfortable and
familiar with, which
is why we chose to extend
Plumber and use that framework.
We also make it easy for them
to test, validate, and confirm
the behavior of
things without needing
to rely on other tools, which
is what we just observed.
The other side of this is how
do we help the Tableau user?
They might not know
anything about R.
anything about Plumber
or any of these tools.
They just are building Tableau
workbooks and dashboards
and visualizations,
and they want access
to the things that
have been built here.
Now, in some organizations,
the R developer and the Tableau
developer might
be the same person
or might work together
on the same team.
In other organizations,
they may have
no idea who one another are.
It might be two totally separate
groups, two totally separate
individuals.
And we wanted that to--
we wanted to support
that type of distinction
between these two roles.
OK, now, at this point, I have
a fully functioning running
Tableau extension
that I've built in R.
The problem is Tableau cannot
access it at this point.
Now, if I was running--
say, for example, I was
running RStudio Desktop
and I had to have
[? R ?] Desktop,
I could stitch these
things together.
I could run the API
inside of RStudio Desktop.
I could open up Tableau Desktop.
I could configure them
to speak to one another,
and that would be great.
But that's a very
limited utility,
because it's still just--
everything is still
local to me.
Everything's still
running on my desktop,
and I'm not going to pass my
laptop around the department
to give people access
to my dashboard.
I need some sort of
centralized hosting mechanism.
On the Tableau
side, that's either
going to be Tableau
online or Tableau server.
On the R side, the easiest
way to distribute and share
and provide access
to this extension
is through RStudio Connect.
And RStudio Connect is
a publishing platform
that supports publishing all
kinds of different R and Python
content, including these
Tableau extensions like the one
that we've built here.
And in order to publish
this to RStudio Connect,
I can select this little
publish button here inside
of the RStudio
development environment.
I can click Publish API,
and then select details
about where I want to
publish it, the name of it,
things like that.
Now, I've already gone
through and published
this API or one
very similar to it,
so I'm going to
just open that now.
So I'm going to come
into RStudio Connect.
Let me navigate to
this particular API.
And then we'll notice there's
a few subtle differences here
in what we look at
in terms of the title
and description of the API,
but the behavior and everything
like that is the same.
So this is that same API that
we were just working with, now
published on RStudio Connect.
And something that
you'll immediately notice
is this looks very different
than what we saw before.
When we ran this
inside of RStudio,
we saw an interface
that looked like this.
If you've done any sort of API
development or API work before,
you're likely familiar with
this type of interface.
It's a very common way of
exposing the functionality
of an API as well as
providing mechanisms
for testing and
validating the API.
And so this is a very
developer-centric view
of what I've built.
On the other side,
once we publish this
to RStudio Connect, we're now
switching gears and saying,
OK, now we're not necessarily
trying to give the developer
tools anymore, but
rather we're trying
to expose this in a way that's
intuitive for the Tableau user
to know what they need to do.
And they don't need to know
how the API request is formed.
They don't need to know
how the endpoint responds.
What they need to know is
how do I use this extension
from Tableau.
And so if we look at
this document that's
been pulled up here
on RStudio Connect,
we could see that's exactly
what this is trying to provide.
It gives the same
title description
that we saw previously, and then
it has this usage section here
that defines--
it's a literal Copy and Paste.
Here's how you use this
inside of Tableau--
copy this script function
into your Tableau workbook
under a calculated field.
Make a change to the
input value to match
what you're trying to
provide from Tableau,
and you're good to go.
And we'll take a look at
that in just a moment.
If we scroll down a
little bit further,
we see additional information
about the arguments
that we're expecting
Tableau to provide
as well as the return
value that we're going
to be giving back to Tableau.
And again, all of
this is being powered
by those additional
annotations that we
added when we introduced
plumbertableau to our API.
One thing that I'll note is
that if we come back just
for a moment to our
development environment
and take a look, when we
defined Tableau return,
we not only described
what we're returning
but we were very specific
about the type of data
that we're going
to be returning.
And the reason for that is
because if we come back now
to RStudio Connect, you'll see
that the Script function is
strongly typed.
This is a Script function,
and then this STR
is a reference to
the fact that we
expect a string value to
come back from the extension.
So because we
provided information
when we developed
this that said, hey,
we're going to return
a character value,
we know when we generate
this documentation
that we should put script
string as the Script String
function using this
particular extension.
And this again, the idea
is just convenience.
We want to make this as easy as
possible for the Tableau user,
and then we come in,
Copy, and Paste this
into their Tableau workbook.
So let's do that.
Let's see this in action.
I'm going to grab this
script that we have here.
We're going to open up a new
workbook on Tableau Online.
I'm going to zoom out.
I've got to connect
to a data source,
so we'll just connect
to the default one.
I'm going to zoom
in here a little bit
just so we can see
a little bit better.
First thing I'm going
to do is just save this,
because in order to use
analytics extensions
we have to have
a saved workbook.
Go ahead and save that.
And then I'm going to
now create a parameter.
We'll call this Input Text, and
this just gives us something
that we can in real
time work with and see.
So we're going to
save this is a string,
and the current value
is "hello world."
Go ahead and hit OK
there, and then let's
actually show this parameter.
So over here on the
right-hand side,
we have this input text field,
and we can use this field
to input anything and it's
referenceable from our Tableau
workbook.
And the significance
now is we can now
go through the process of
creating a calculated field.
We'll call this caps,
and here's where
we're going to paste in that
Script function that we've
copied from RStudio Connect.
And you'll notice the
first argument here
is the location of this
extension on RStudio Connect.
And so this is the
path to the extension
as hosted on RStudio
Connect, and then the second
and any subsequent
arguments are the values--
are a reference to the
values that we want to pass
from Tableau to the extension.
So I'm going to replace string
value with Input Text, which
is a reference to our parameter
that we created, and then hit
OK.
And now, we're going to
bring this calculated field
into our workbook, so it'll
take a moment to load.
And then we're going
to-- it automatically
defaults to a color value,
but we don't want that.
We'll call this-- we'll
change this to be a label.
And here, we can see--
there's a way to expand it,
and I never remember how.
But if we hover, we can see
the capitalized rendered text
of "hello world."
And just to showcase that it
doesn't just do "hello world,"
we can come over and say, "this
is an analytics extension."
And if we hover again, we see
this is an analytics extension
in full capitalization.
So we've gone through
the full process
of we've developed this
extension inside of RStudio
or some other editor using
Plumber and plumbertableau.
We've published the extension
to RStudio Connect, where
it can then be accessed and
used by Tableau users who
have to come in--
let me come back to RStudio, OK.
Come in, copy the script value,
paste it into their workbook
under a calculated
field, and then supply
the appropriate values to
that extension function.
And in our case,
that appropriate
value-- if I pull
this up one more time.
An appropriate value
is this Input Text.
Typically-- again, very,
very trivial example.
So in practice, what
we might see here
is we might see something like
multiple values being passed
in from the
underlying data source
that my Tableau workbook
is built on top of.
And then we get really
nice functionality,
where if a user comes in and
filters the data or changes
the view or
otherwise manipulates
the underlying data, that
triggers this extension
to reevaluate with new data.
So this is a very responsive
real time interaction
between some third
party service.
In our case, that
third party service
is RStudio Connect that's
hosting this R script,
this R function
that we're running,
and it's responding in real time
to how users are interacting
with the Tableau workbook.
Just to highlight that,
let me come back here.
So here's an example.
Let me see if this will
pull up and render.
Sometimes it's a
little bit finicky,
but we'll see if we can
make something happen.
So here's an example
of something that's
a little bit more involved.
So we have-- once
this pulls up here.
We have two different-- actually
two different extensions
that are being hosted
on RStudio Connect.
One is an R extension that
does real time outlier
detection giving us--
given a set of input data.
So we consider-- this is
a transactional data set
that we're working with here.
So we consider sales and
profit for a given customer,
and then based on
sales and profit,
we determine which customers
appear to be outliers given
the totality of the data set.
That all happens in R. Then
we have another extension
written in Python.
So there's a companion
package to plumbertableau
called Fast API Tableau that
does the same thing, just
on the Python side.
And so we have another extension
written in Python-- in fact,
let me just pull that
up while that's loading.
And this extension takes a
previously trained model,
some input from Tableau
and uses that input
to generate new
predicted values.
And that allows us to do--
in the case of our
workbook, what we're doing
is we're saying,
OK, given what we
know about this customer and
their transactional history,
what amount of profit
do we predict out
of this customer for
this transaction?
And so we take that
predicted profit value.
We compare it to the actual
profit of the transaction,
and then we can identify
under and overperformers
based on that
metric of comparing,
predicted to realize profit.
Let me just open up
that example here, OK.
So this view is a little
bit different than what
we had seen previously.
And the reason for this is
the Fast API Tableau package
has a slightly
different interface when
it comes to rendering the
documentation that we generate
for Tableau users,
and there will
be an update that gets made to
the plumbertableau package that
brings a similar style
interface there as well.
So there's a more unified
feeling between the two.
But we see the
same behavior here.
We can come in, and
we can say using
Tableau workbooks, same thing.
We can Copy and Paste this value
into R or Tableau workbook.
We have a description
of what we're doing
and the values we're expecting.
If I come back to
Tableau, here--
let me see if I can
get this to work.
I just want to
showcase what it might
look like in a more
comprehensive example,
and so we should be able to
get this to come through here
in a minute.
It just takes a minute to
wake Tableau up sometimes.
So if I come in
here, I just want
to highlight-- this is
we had-- sometimes it
has a problem rendering.
But if I look at
this description
of this particular
extension, we can see,
here, I'm referencing,
again, the location
of the extension itself as it
relates to RStudio Connect,
and then here are the actual
values that I'm passing in
from my workbook to Tableau.
So I have five different values
that I'm passing in here.
These are all inputs to
the model that I trained,
and then those values get
used on the Connect side
or on the extension side to
generate new predicted values
when it comes to
profit and return
that value back into here.
Yeah, and I think because
we reset the extension
in the middle of
this, it timed out,
so it wasn't able to
complete its trip.
Anyway, so that's at a very
like I said simplistic level.
That's the idea behind
plumbertableau and by extension
Fast API Tableau.
Is to say look, let's say that
I have some business logic,
I have some complex arithmetic,
or machine learning,
or whatever the
case is that I need
to do as some real time
interaction with my Tableau
workbook takes place, and
whatever it is that I'm trying
to do extends beyond what
Tableau natively gives me
in terms of capabilities.
And that's often the case when
it comes to machine learning.
There's some rudimentary
machine learning capabilities
in Tableau, but if
I'm looking to do
something a little bit
more complex or involved
or something like
outlier detection, which
is one of the examples
that we provide
in our online
repository, then this
becomes a really
compelling use case
because I can
essentially say I'm
going to take the data
that I have in Tableau,
I'm going to send it off
somewhere or something
to be done to it, and then I'm
going to get the results back.
And in this case, we've shown
I can send that data off
to RStudio Connect.
This extension can execute and
then return the results back
into Tableau, and
I can then further
use those results to
improve my analysis
or enhance my
visualization, or whatever
I'm doing with the results once
they come back is up to me.
There's a few caveats that I
think are worth putting out.
One is Tableau is
interesting in the sense
that if I'm passing in--
this is a pretty, again,
trivial too example,
but if I'm referencing a
large underlying data set
and I'm trying to pass that data
set in bulk to my extension,
it depends on how I'm actually
calculating my calculated field
inside of Tableau, because
Tableau will either
send one request
with all the data,
or it will send one request
per observation, which can
dramatically slow things down.
So imagine I've got
100,000 rows of data.
I could-- and accidentally
if I haven't set things
up the right way, I
could accidentally
send up sending 100,000
requests every time I
try to use the extension,
and that's certainly
going to be much less efficient
than sending just one request
with 100,000 observations.
And so we have some
documentation around things
to look into and how to go
about reasoning around how
to set up Tableau
so that it sends
a request along the
appropriate dimension
so that you end up working
as efficiently as possible.
The one other thing
that I'll mention
that we haven't discussed
so far is how do we
set these things up from--
how do we set up the connection
between Tableau and RStudio
Connect, and that's a
little bit beyond the scope
of plumbertableau
itself, but I think
it's worth just
understanding how that works.
So if I come back to the
Home page of Tableau Online
and come to Settings, as
an admin in Tableau Online,
if I come over to
Extensions, here's
where I can do a
couple of things.
One, I can enable
Analytics Extensions.
So about halfway down the page,
there's Analytics Extensions.
I would choose to enable
those for my site.
And then there isn't
anything pre-configured,
so I need to create a new
connection from this option
list, also like
analytics extensions
API, which is the final option.
And then in here, we can
say-- we can give it a name--
RStudio Connect.
Provide the hostname--
myrstudioconnect.com,
and the port, whatever
that might be.
The username is always
rstudio-connect,
and then the password here is
any valid RStudio Connect User
API Key.
And the thing to understand
about this setup-- again, two
things.
One, this is managed and done
by the Tableau administrator,
so individual users aren't
managing connections
at this level.
This is done at the
administrative level.
And then when you create
a workbook as a user,
you can select which connection
you want to actually use
from that workbook.
So it's done by
the administrator.
The other thing is this
password is centrally used.
And what I mean by that is
whatever API key is input here
by the Tableau admin
is the key that
will be used any time an
extension uses this connection.
So if this key is
my own personal key,
that means my personal
RStudio Connect
user has to be added
to every extension that
is published in order for
it to be used from Tableau.
Our recommended approach
here is to create
a service account called
Tableau or Tableau Extension.
Really call it
whatever you want.
But then use an API key from
that service account as the key
that you provide here
in the setup on Tableau,
and then add that Tableau user--
again, whatever you
happen to have called
that service account.
Add that user to
every extension that's
published so that they have--
so that Tableau has the ability
to call out to that extension.
OK, and I think like--
again, trivial example
in terms of what we're
actually doing but
hopefully highlights
the flexibility
of this approach
and the way in which
it can be used to extend
the functionality of Tableau
beyond just what's
already there.
Anyway, that's
plumbertableau in a nutshell.